tf à 20 heures avec jean claude bourret
fin du tour de france pour l'emploi de
raymond barre aujourd'hui auch et
toulouse
le débat sur les salaires 2% seulement
des contribuables déclarent plus de 5
fois le smic
les tueurs de l'ardèche le ratissage de
la région n'a pour l'instant rien donné
après le flottement de l'escudo
austérité pour sauver l'économie du
portugal
l'évasion d'herbert t'cap leur relance
la diffusion d'un film inédit en france
des extraits à la fin du journal
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir ça
rentre déjà et ça bouchonne modestement
voilà le premier commentaire de bison
futé en ce vendredi 25 août 1977
finalement c'est tant mieux car
précisément bison futé avait suggéré aux
aoûtiens de commencer à rentrer dès
aujourd'hui afin d'éviter les deux
journées critique demain samedi et
dimanche les premiers assaut donné par
les aoûtiens a commencé au petit matin
depuis la frontière espagnole la
nationale 10 a vu pousser ses premiers
bouchons
certains d'entre eux atteignez la
respectable longueur de 12 km notamment
près de bayonne que vous voyez sur ces
images mais c'est une douzaine de
bouchons au total seulement qui ont
handicapé l'écoulement du trafic sur
cette nationale 10 dans l'ensemble cette
journée de vendredi est donc plutôt
satisfaisante pour les responsables de
la circulation routière le deuxième
point d'interrogation c'est la météo qui
pas rentrer autant le faire sous le
soleil
les routes sont ainsi moins glissante et
donc moins dangereuses alors côté soleil
le spécialiste de tf1 en connaît un
rayon si j'ose dire puisqu'il a réussi
ce tour de force de bronze et entre les
nuages du mois d'août guira la rivière
compte tenu de vos nouveaux calculs est
ce que vous êtes ce soir aussi
pessimistes qu à 13h pour le week end
eh bien vous le voyez si la france était
dans cette zone de haute pression ou si
vous préférez si cette zone de votre
pression était sur la france nous
aurions un bon week-end vous le voyez
sur la carte n'est pas tout à fait ça
qui se passe est au contraire une zone
de basse pression qui se trouve sur
l'europe occidentale et donc sur la
france avec deux zones de pluie plupart
titularisé une d'une part sur le massif
central la suisse les régions de l'est
et partiellement sur les halles mais
accompagnés d'airs chauds quand même
plus au sud par exemple cet après midi
il y avait 25 à perpignan et 27 ajaccio
donc en dehors mais à proximité de la
zone de pipelines deuxième donne depuis
également bien marqué sur la bretagne
qui pénètre sur la france si celle ci
est suivi d'air beaucoup plus frais
voilà ce sont ces caractéristiques qui
vont dominer le temps pour l'ensemble du
week-end alors pour demain et dimanche
une première région tout l'est de la
france le jura les halles une partie du
sud est et jusqu'à la corse où les
nuages on est très abondant avec des
pluies intermittentes et des orages
évidemment pas continu les 48 heures
enfin un temps quand même très médiocre
mais dans un premier moment assez chaud
devenant plus frais dimanche attention
peut-être des chutes de neige qui de
haute altitude où elles vont d'abord ce
site et descendront en moyenne montagne
et puis alors l'autre zone c'est la
bretagne et l'ouest de la france où il
va faire déjà plus frais des deux mains
avec des vents de nord-ouest encore
assez fort et quelques giboulées mais
par contre dimanche sur ces régions le
temps s'améliorera net
et puis alors entre les deux du nord et
du bassin parisien à l'aquitaine au
massif central les nouvelles pluies qui
pénétreront qui vont être précédée
disons du languedoc jusqu'aux ardennes
d'un temps d'abord assez beau mais
donnant quelques orages dans
l'après-midi de demain
et puis alors au contraire dimanche une
amélioration assez marquée sur le golfe
du lion avec établissements du ministre
a alors que partout ailleurs les pluies
vont devenir un peu plus sporadique et
prendre un caractère de giboulées mais
il y aura quand même donc des averses
sur toutes ces régions de la france
jusqu'à dimanche
après quimper après montpellier colmar
et charleville le premier ministre
monsieur raymond barre et depuis hier
soir dans le sud ouest il s'agit de la
cinquième et dernière étape de son tour
de france de l'emploi
ce matin raymond barre était à toulouse
jacques hébert toulouse capitale de
l'aéronautique française ou au cours de
deux réunions de travail qui l'aï ce
matin avec les responsables locaux les
syndicats fo cgc cftc
le premier ministre a bien entendu
parler des problèmes de l'aérospatiale à
toulouse qui dit emplois dit
construction d'un renouveau raymond
barre a confirmé la construction de
l'avion à 200 en coopération avec les
allemands et les anglais
il a également annoncé qu'elle est être
étudié les possibilités de mise en
chantier d'un avion militaire nord 260
durant tout son périple sur l'emploi
excepté charleville les syndicats cgt
cfdt fn ont boudé cette visite de
raymond barre en organisant quelques
cortège et manifestations le premier
ministre devait d'ailleurs dressé un
premier bilan de ce voyage éclair dans
cinq villes françaises
écouter raymond barre je retire
de ces visites que j'ai fait dans les
diverses villes de france
deux ans c'est le premier enseignement
c'est que il y a une volonté très nette
de tous les intéressés non seulement
l'administration mais aussi les
représentants des entreprises des
représentants d exploitation artisanale
de remplir leur devoir à l'égard des
jeunes
il considère que c'est un devoir
national que d'aider les jeunes à
trouver un premier emploi
en dépit de la situation difficile dans
laquelle se trouvent les entreprises
la deuxième observation que j'ai faite
c'est que l'économie française traverse
est certes des difficultés et sur
certains points dans certains secteurs
des mesures vont intervenir pour
soutenir l'activité économique mais que
dans l'ensemble nous étions engagés sur
la voie du redressement économique et
qu'il y avait partout compréhension de
la situation difficile dans laquelle se
trouvait non seulement notre pays
mais tous les pays du monde occidental
et en même temps volonté de touche de
surmonter la crise et de retrouver par
un effort continu la voie du
développement économique
duplaix l'emploi et du progrès social
après toulouse c'était pour le premier
ministre le survol en hélicoptère des
régions du sud-ouest touchés par les
tragiques inondations des 9 et 8 juillet
dernier arrivé à auch raymond barre
s'est longuement entretenu avec les
parlementaires locaux
les dirigeants agricoles et les
représentants des associations de
sinistrés
là aussi absence des syndicats qui
manifestaient dans la ville il ya
seulement quelques instants le premier
ministre faisait le point des mesures
gouvernementales prises après ces
inondations
les mesures qui ont été prises par le
gouvernement témoigne de sa volonté de
manifester d'une façon particulière la
solidarité nationale et de la manifester
rapide je peux constater aujourd'hui que
la circulation routière et ferroviaire a
été rétabli dans les meilleurs délais
que les sous que le téléphone a
fonctionné moins de dix jours après le
sinistre et que le fonds de secours a
fonctionné immédiatement moins de trois
semaines après les inondations
les premiers dossiers ont pu être réglés
par le comité départemental de secours
un mois et demi après ces inondations 20
millions de francs soit 2 milliard et 2
milliards de francs anciens de centimes
et ont déjà été chef délégué au préfet
et des règlements interviennent auprès
des particuliers et des entreprises de
façon quotidienne
monsieur raymond barre a précisé
aujourd'hui qu'il n'avait pris aucune
décision sur son éventuelle inscription
dans une circonscription qu'il
choisirait lors des prochaines
législatives
on avait parlé d'une candidature
possible du premier ministre à lyon je
me réserve a expliqué monsieur vraiment
bar d'annoncer moi même la
circonscription où je serai candidat est
le suppléant que j'aurai choisi georges
séguy et edmond maire se rencontreront
le 31 août prochain
la rencontre aura lieu à 14h30 au siège
de la cgt cette rencontre entre la cgt
et la cfdt a pour but de faire le point
de la situation à la rentrée et
d'échanger des opinions sur les
perspectives d'action à court terme
le débat sur l'éventail des salaires se
poursuit au sein de la gauche
un éventail qui selon le parti
communiste devrait être ramenée de 1 à 5
pour l'instant on ne parle encore que
des salaires et non des autres
catégories de revenus et on ne tient pas
compte des effets de l'imposition sur le
revenu
le débat est donc loin d'être clos alain
bel air non moins importants que
l'éventail des salaires il y à
l'éventail des revenus dont
ménages disposent effectivement après
l'impôt cet éventail on peut l'apprécier
grâce aux statistiques tirées des
déclarations fiscales l'apprécier
seulement car il y à toutes les formes
évasion fiscale de fraude que montrent
ces statistiques
tout d'abord que l'impôt avec son barème
progressif qui pénalise les revenus
élevés et le quotient familial qui
avantage les familles atténue les
inégalités cela se traduit dans les
chiffres
en 75 42 % des contribuables ont déclaré
moins de vingt mille francs et payer
moins de 9% du total de l'impôt à
l'autre bout de la pyramide un peu plus
de 4 % des contribuables dix fois moins
on déclarait plus de 70 mille francs et
payer le tiers du total de lincou
deuxième constatation malgré le barème
progressif l'éventail des revenus reste
considérable en effet si l'on comparé
des revenus des quelque dix mille
contribuables qui déclarent le plus au
fisc et ceux des deux millions trois
cent mille personnes âgées qui touchent
le minimum vieillesse
on arrive à un écart après impôts de 1 à
rappelons qu'il s'agit de revenus non de
salaire les déclarations les plus
importantes comprennent généralement
plusieurs salaires des bénéfices
industriels et commerciaux ainsi que des
revenus de valeurs mobilières
la troisième constatation enfin c'est le
petit nombre des très gros revenus
seulement 2% des contribuables vers et
leur pouvoir d'achat rogné par la
politique salariale de la gauche gagnant
cinq fois plus que le smic
mais encore une fois nous n'avons pu
prendre en compte que les revenus
déclarés au fisc
le premier ministre portugais monsieur
mario soares a annoncé hier soir que les
scudo ne serait pas dévaluer mais qu'il
flotte serait une mesure destinée à
freiner le déficit de la balance des
paiements portugaise qui va s'ajouter à
la réduction des 10% des dépenses
prévues au budget de l'état à une hausse
des combustibles et à une augmentation
des taux d'intérêt de près de 4%
mario soares a donc choisi la date
symbolique du 25 août pour annoncer les
nouvelles mesures d'austérité au
portugal après le 25 avril 74 date de la
révolution des capitaines après le 25
novembre 75 échec d'une tentative de
coup d'état militaire d'extrême gauche
après le 25 février 77 ou les scudo a
été évaluée de 15% ce 25 août marque une
nouvelle étape dans l'histoire
économique aux politiques du portugal
ladislas de hoyos oui il ré deux slogans
que les dirigeants portugais voudrait
bien faire admettre l'un le portugal vit
au dessus de ses moyens l'autre il est
impossible de sortir de la crise sans
emprunter ici ou là bon l'escudo flotte
qui n'est plus calquée sur le dollar et
le prix de l'essence a battu tous les
records risquent le litre de super face
à trois francs 12 ce qui sera sans doute
la mesure la plus impopulaire
quant aux c'est au prix de quels efforts
et ans hugues et s'étaient précipités au
lendemain de la révolution pour acheter
des voitures d'occasion
oui vraiment il ya de quoi être moreau
mais curieusement si le dollar n'a plus
rien à voir avec la valeur de l'escudo
c'est bien pour lui qu'il s'est mis à
flotter
car sans ces mesures d'austérité jamais
sans doute le portugal n'aurait
bénéficié de l'aide occidentale à savoir
750 millions de dollars qui vont
renflouer les caisses vides et cela dès
le mois prochain pour la plus grande
joie notamment que ces rapatriés du
mozambique l'angola oublier bissao et
dont certains sont d'ailleurs prêts à
retourner en afrique toujours à la
recherche d'un emploi
tenez ce on était arrivé à un tel point
que les prix à la consommation avaient
augmenté pour les six premiers mois de
cette année de 40 % par rapport à la
moyenne de l'indien la sacro-sainte
morue qui faisaient le plat national
devient introuvable pourquoi parce que
les portugais n'empêchait qu'une très
faible partie et qu'il s'était habitué à
l'acheter aux islandais
résultat plus d'argent plus de mots
russie il y a deux responsables à cette
faillite économique
1 l'augmentation disproportionnée des
salaires au lendemain la révolution des
oeillets et cela au moment où le
portugal rendait ses anciennes colonies
2 la fuite des capitaux lorsque les
communistes avaient fait peur aux
capitalistes en entreprenant de réformer
la vie économique du pays
au risque d'être détesté par tout ce qui
était à sa gauche mario soares avait à
son tour réformer la réforme agraire
autrement dit sans revenir à l'ancien
système féodal il avait rendu des terres
à bon nombre de petits propriétaires
déjà ce avait soulevé les plus vives
protestations du parti communiste cette
fois il est allé bien plus loin sans
craindre semble-t-il de provoqué la
riposte de la centrale syndicale
mario soares a tout bonnement remis en
question certains contrats collectifs
qui protégeait les salariés il est vrai
que ménageant la chèvre et le chou le
premier ministre taillé dans son propre
budget du gouvernement et a par ailleurs
relevé le taux d'intérêt pour appeler
les épargnants
reste à savoir oui il reste à savoir
s'il sera écoutée dany louzac le
gendarme blessé par les tueurs fous de
l'ardèche est dans un état grave
le bulletin de santé indique ce soir
toujours que les médecins sont réservés
bien que ce gendarme et repris
connaissance
les médecins de la clinique saint-eloi
de montpellier espère cependant le
sauver pendant ce temps une importante
opération de recherche se poursuit afin
d'arrêter les trois gangsters qui en 48
heures ont tué deux personnes et en ont
blessé trois autres dont deux gendarmes
une importante opération de recherches
en vue de retrouver la trace des
gangsters qui ont abattu mercredi soir
deux personnes et en ont blessé trois
autres dont deux gendarmes a été lancé
cet après midi dans la région du puy en
velay le quadrillage minutieux auquel
participent notamment un escadron de
gendarmes mobiles venus en renfort de
romans dans la drôme ainsi que d'un
hélicoptère se déroule dans un rayon de
15 à 20 km autour du chef lieu du
département
les témoignages qui avait recueilli la
gendarmerie au cours de la journée
d'hier n'ont pas permis de déceler
l'éventuelle présence des tueurs dans la
région et les patrouilles qui ont
continué toute la nuit
l'on donné aucun résultat quant aux
habitants des villages environnants le
puis ils commencent à s'inquiéter de
l'éventuelle présence de tueurs dans
leur voisinage
le colonel petillot commandant le
groupement de la gendarmerie de la haute
loire tient à les rassurer
je ne pense pas quand même que la
population doivent doivent les craindre
systématiquement il ne faut pas quand
même que s'installe une psychose de peur
dans ce département
d'ailleurs ils sont ils encore donc
serrières non je crois plutôt que les
populations devraient chercher à nous
aider par les observations que qu'elle
peut faire sans rechercher le contact
est bien entendu avec ces gens là qui on
le sait sont extrêmement dangereux donc
si vous avez des renseignements
n'hésitez pas à téléphoner à la
gendarmerie la plus proche
le championnat du monde sur piste a
commencé aujourd'hui à san cristobal au
venezuela en présence de la fine fleur
du cyclisme mondial
la première médaille d'or est allée à
l'allemand de l'est le tard tom sur le
kilomètre départ arrêté un commentaire
d'alain escoubet bien que cette image de
la télévision vénézuélienne ne vous le
montre pas le départ de lautard tom
s'est effectuée arrêté c'est à dire
qu'il lui a fallu lancer sa machine le
plus rapidement possible pour atteindre
au plus vite sa vitesse maximum ce qui
est déjà fait semble-t-il prêt ce n'est
pas forcément le plus difficile le plus
dur en réalité dans ce genre d'épreuve
c'est de tenir la vitesse maximale soit
environ 60 kilomètres heure sans autre
horizon que le bout de sa roue essayez
en ce week-end et vous verrez que record
du monde sur cette distance appartient
aux danois fred borg en une minute 4
secondes et 49 centièmes mais le tard
tom se bouclera lui ses trois tours en
une minute 4 secondes et 85 100e
devançant de plus de deux secondes
allemands de l'ouest schumacher 2e et le
suisse les nordmann troisième faute en
français permet l'aisne
il termine à la 6e place
avec jean pierre pernaut d'autres
informations importantes
oui d'abord un nouveau tremblement de
terre en indonésie ou même endroit mais
plus faible que celui de la semaine
dernière 6 degré 4 sur l'échelle de
richter qui en compte neuf il n'y aurait
pas de victimes nous n'avons pas
d'autres détails pour l'instant
je reviens l'actualité sportive car il
ya à la suite de la coupe de l'america
en ce moment on sait que le bateau
france 1 a perdu toutes ses chances
d'être opposées aux américains mais la
lutte reste très serré entre le bateau
australien et le voilier suédois vous
voyez cette course la dernière régate
aide est remporté par australia il reste
encore plusieurs épreuves de
qualification avant la grande finale
je vous rappelle que les états unis
n'ont jamais perdu cette coupe de
l'america la cgt la cfdt envisage des
actions revendicatives à edf gdf le 6
septembre on vient de l'apprendre ces
actions pourraient aller jusqu'à la
grève 0,9 pour cent le chiffre n'est pas
encore officiel mais ce serait la hausse
des prix au mois de juillet plus plus
forte qu'en juin où il avait été de 0,8
pour cent
nous attendions un indice fort vient de
dire raymond barre puisque en juillet il
y a eu la hausse des automobiles des
loyers et de quelques services bilan du
contrôle des prix sur les lieux de
vacances en juillet et août 2005 sans
vérification et 500 procès-verbaux
souvent pour dépassement des prises
autorisées
les contrôles vont se poursuivre dans
les semaines qui viennent
la grève des contrôleurs aériens
français n'a pas provoqué de
perturbations aujourd'hui le trafic a
été normale et tous les vols prévus ont
été assurés mais il ya eu quand même de
nombreux retards très léger encore une
polémique autour de la catastrophe
aérienne de tenerife après la découverte
d'uranium sur les lieux de l'accident un
quotidien de tenerife affirme qu'il est
radioactif cet uranium est qu'il ya
danger pour les habitants qui ont gardé
en souvenir des morceaux des deux avions
réponse de boeing il y a trois cent dix
kilos d'uranium appauvri dans les
ailerons de tous nos appareils donc
aucun danger de radioactivité tentative
d'assassinât contre le procureur fédéral
de karlsruhe en allemagne un attentat
manqué car la police a désamorcé à temps
une machine infernale qui aurait pu
envoyer 40 de roquettes à la fois elle
avait été placée dans un appartement
juste en face du bureau du procureur
la tentative a été revendiquée par un
groupe extrémiste fraction armée rouge
fin des travaux du conseil central de
l'organisation de libération de la
palestine olp a confirmé son rejet de la
résolution 242 du conseil de sécurité
même si elle était modifiée cette
résolution prévoit le retrait d'israël
aux frontières de 67 mais elle
impliquait aussi la reconnaissance de
fait de l'état d'israël enfin également
de la conférence de lagos contre
l'apartheid la conférence a demandé
l'abandon de toutes formes de
coopération militaires et nucléaires
avec l'afrique du sud south 27 à tokyo
il a quitté pékin la nuit dernière à
taïwan on est soulagés car si les états
unis souhaitent un rapprochement avec
pékin
cela ne se fera pas au prix de l'abandon
des relations avec formose
le premier ministre désigné jan smith a
rejeté le nouveau plan anglo-américain
de règlement du problème rhodésien un
plan qui prévoyait la dissolution de
l'armée rhodésienne remplacés par des
forces de l'onu
météo mauvaise en france les dates
d'ouverture de la chasse viennent d'être
modifiées dans le nord et en région
parisienne pour la région parisienne
report du 11 au 18 septembre pour le
département de l'aisne report du 18 au
25 septembre il y aura aussi des
restrictions de chasse certains jours de
la semaine dans plusieurs départements
alors pour être sûr de ne pas se tromper
les deux millions trois cent mille
chasseurs ont tout intérêt à se
renseigner dans les mairies la
production mondiale de cigarettes a
augmenté de trois pour cent
soixante-seize on a fumé 4080 milliards
de cigarettes dans le monde en 76
la france en a produit 86 milliards très
loin derrière la chine premier
producteur mondial avec plus de 700
milliards de cigarettes une visite
royale ce matin au palais de l'elysée
celle de la reine margrethe du danemark
accompagnée du prince henrik le couple
royal a été reçu à déjeuner par le
président de la république et madame
giscard d'estaing enfin dimanche un
tiercé à deauville 20 partants dans le
prix françois andré une affaire à suivre
bien sûr demain à 13h avec andré théron
le président du conseil italien monsieur
andreotti fournira des explications sur
l'évasion du criminel de guerre nazi
kappler le 13 septembre prochain devant
la chambre des députés un communiqué de
la présidence du conseil précise
après cette évasion là conscience des
italiens est profondément troublé et
notre gouvernement attend que la
république fédérale d'allemagne prenne
une initiative démontrant sa
condamnation d'un passé qui ne peut être
oubliée en allemagne fédérale
madame caplet relais
ouch de l'ancien colonel ss a précisé un
journal italien par téléphone qu'elle
s'était réfugiée avec son mari dans une
petite chambre en pleine campagne très
loin dans bourg madame cas plaire
également confirmé qu'elle avait vendu
l'exclusivité du récit de l'évasion de
son mari dans une malle à une agence de
presse allemande qui commencerait la
publication dès la semaine prochaine
l'évasion de l'ancien colonel ss kappler
et l'émotion que cette affaire a soulevé
en europe ont relancé également un film
sorti il y a trois ans mais boudée par
le public
dans ce film intitulé représailles c'est
richard burton qui tient le rôle du
colonel ss kappler un film qui retrace
la terrible exécution de 335 otages
italiens dans des grottes par les hommes
du colonel ss kappler en mars 1944 une
exécution qui faisait suite à un
attentat commis à rome au moment du
passage d'une colonne ss une trentaine
de soldats allemands avaient trouvé la
mort dans cet attentat
c'est ce film inédit en france dont nous
vous proposons un premier extrait qui
résume parfaitement bien toute l'horreur
de cette action de représailles après
cet attentat que vous allez voir dans un
instant
les hommes des colonels kappler ont pris
trois cent trente cinq otages
ouais
après cet attentat donc que vous venez
de voir reconstituer les hommes du
colonel ss kappler prenait 335 otage sur
les ordres de leur chef et c'est dans
les grottes haderer tine que les ss du
colonel cas plaire on a battu les
italiens pris au hasard et en tout cas
innocents de l'attentât
côté
c'était donc la reconstitution au cinéma
d'un événement qui n'a pas été du tout
du cinéma qui s'est passé en mars 1944
en italie
335 innocents qui ont été abattus par
les ss vers 23h10 et jean pierre pernaut
qui vous présentera le dernier journal
toute l'équipe de tf1 actualité vous
souhaite une bonne soirée
bonsoir